hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the last of us dlc
left behind now I apologize for the
delay on this one I've been incredibly
busy recording stuff today and I don't
know why I picked today of all days to
record things with other people and
everyone around the world with butter
hair I literally have butter hair today
I haven't even had a chance to take a
shower and this was last on my list of
stuff to do I kept trying to record and
then people just suddenly came about
that's not good all are we doing here
okay so [ __ ] about that old man and a
little girl yeah sooner we find them the
sooner we get out of here make sure this
area is clear seriously what was the
point of all that gladly got me the bow
again I really like it go around back
oh this is a great start I did good I'm
glad I'm really happy with myself and
the choices that I make okay no number
one I just got the boat I was a little
pre-emptive I'm gonna wait till they
pass this time before I just oh it's too
bad for you guys for that guy
more specifically can I pick that up
please thank you how about these over
here these all look awfully convenient
over here okay now that I get the bow
back it wouldn't be a Marga blyer let's
play if I didn't screw up as soon as I
started playing so anyway Oh
octopus records I wonder if they have
the dough dance soundtrack that's my
comedic genius it drives people away
okay anyway so we're following this
weird trail of blood into the ducts I'm
assuming I didn't need to kill those
guys most of the time here you can just
around him especially when you're le
whoa whoa is that a Nazi was a Nazi
doing here
oh it's a medic oh okay whoops not a
Nazi all right duck the quarter wait
come on
yeah yeah that's messed up man
Oh
alright that was more of it yeah there I
remember getting a note before about how
[Music]
they were talking about someone named
Regan and I don't know Ellis I'm not
exactly sure but yeah they tried to save
one and they couldn't or something like
that hey why don't you check over by
this bunch of zom zoms how do I make
whoo yeah go over there get him get him
get him get him
yeah mop him up I think those are
clickers so I think they should kill him
right away right yep that one looks
pretty dead and the other one probably
Walter yeah good job me I'm a genius
Oh do I need to go down there oh okay
okay I don't know if he's still alive
down there if we got not off both of
them got Nam done I'm gonna assume I
hear the groans of one person so
[Applause]
I almost feel bad okay now I need to get
them away from where I need to go go
over there I'll get to drop down here
[Applause]
okay quickly quickly quickly quickly Oh
quickly so quickly I hate being around
those things pick up some arrows or no
what was that where over there no
beeping okay to see security gate
there's no power and I know why I was
paranoid about that okay just go stay
low for a bit because there might be
guys and I don't want to look stupid in
front of everyone I need a way around
okie-dokie you want a way around I'll
cook you up a way around this yellow
line seems to be attracting me to this
location so I'll go this way I'll pick
up this bottle of vodka okay can i craft
anything now I don't know if I can yeah
uh health kit that's good enough for me
I could have made it health kid I was
just giving it to Joe I guess I still
need to get the supplies away okay I
don't see anything in the air just yet
what is that what do we got over here
something important
loser I didn't mean to touch that thing
that was always so important to you I
don't see anyone where are they what was
that seriously oh I see oh come on do
these guys not give up how do we know
the zombies over there so if I throw
stuff here yeah zombies come on mess him
up mr. Mesenbourg
fight a little stupid fight a fight in
vitam kill him kill him kill him
oh that's a little yeah mess him up you
got him you got him
delicious no baloney oh that was baloney
what's gonna work out perfectly I should
have stayed buying this counter that
would have been even better dang I was
so close to winning oh that one wasn't
my fault that was not my fault oh okay
my bad what was that
okay so I'm gonna get behind this so
that I have a place of cover where they
probably don't go
okay come out are you doing over here
you better get over there oh that's so
pathetic you killed them all last time
and this time you just decided not to
bunch of losers
all those guys getting killed oh did you
die that's so sad alright I actually
liked the parts with the bow before I
liked playing around with it oh no no no
no oh he was just in the shadows that
would I even possibly see him did I get
him
oh I think I get him who's good blind
shot I guess I couldn't even see what I
was shooting it it's a little darker for
me than it is for the recording so
[Music]
I don't know if this still works while
their afternoon I may switch to the gun
because I mean come on
oh you no no right blam my brains going
no stop talking you're making me look
like a fool
thank you thank you for dying it was
that the last one come on you son of a
[ __ ] you're making me look so bad I
swear I'm better than this
I was those zombies didn't kill a single
damn one of them that killed all of them
last time that is such bull pony that is
I got ripped off majorly in that window
just absolute rubbish yeah that's right
come on you need to investigate that or
I'll go around you you guys have to
admit how rubbish that was I just healed
why why is my health back could I not
just oh oh yeah I got to hold it down
until it's done that's right that's how
that works okay
I could probably just get around this
guy but like I'm angry at him so I want
to kill him I don't know if I can get a
head shot from here oh yeah that was
weird an arrow just zipped past my head
there gotcha you douche ya douche nozzle
I'm almost out of arrows but yeah screw
you you [ __ ] all right oh and I can get
the arrow back thank you so much
oh that took way longer than I think it
needed to apologize for my poor
performance but you have to admit come
on those samsa worthless seriously how
many of these like how much power these
people willing to lose just to try to
get these like two people owe this back
where I started
okay so if I go this way it'll send me
back towards Joel just moronic
just moronic just give it up I guess
some more people they lose the less
mouths they have to fade no no you don't
you don't want to get ambushed ya mean
like no one doesn't zoom us with arrows
well I would be just so awful
whoa bye
that's a close one over there better
check Bailey whoa okay
oh you gotta be kidding me oh come on
screw it we're going guns blazing
yep just like that that's how I roll
five shots three misses it's all good no
no I meant to miss I meant to miss yeah
was it elaborate yeah I do I'm missing
two but that don't matter because I hate
you we got two shots left
I need a throwable thing so I can get in
closer to Nathan I'm out of throwables
let me see if there was a throwable back
here that I can okay that's good god
damn it where's all the throw balls
there we go come on come on come on I
want to play come on I want to play I
know I'm not playing well right now but
I'm just gonna Oh master Rick y'all lose
we're gonna get bricked in the dick
that's what you're gonna be you're gonna
get bricked door joke someone doesn't
break me in the dick oh no don't mess
with my horsey you don't got enough
I have got you babe right nice sights I
don't have any arrows you left so I'm
just gonna break it all I don't see
anyone else I think he might be the last
one if I am mistaken yeah that's it
that'll okay so wait a minute how do I
get back I have no idea maybe I'll be
smart and go around like these clowns
didn't good I can build bombs and one
cool Humana can bastard where am I going
no idea five a hint
what am I supposed to do oh this guy
Hey
hey buddy where you going so quickly
good show by a little girl isn't that
embarrassing
who's that another one another one
coming up this year oh okay I see how
you are great stupidly I'm not very good
at smack talk so don't expect love for
me all right so that was a lot of them I
just don't know what else I need I don't
have a oh oh okay that was just the
fabric okay I got to do something but I
don't know what Oh Oh over there okay
bring it on come over here
seriously it's gonna be good for you
gonna be real real beneficial for you to
come over it's gonna be super duper
duper awesome if you come over it's
gonna be just the dumb most delightful
thing for do
Oh No thank you for the ammo it was
awfully helpful in my endeavor to kill
you bastards yeah hey that was all okay
that's all I need to do just kill them
all how simple can it get so now what I
need to do I guess I need to go down and
open it up why have the key to that I
don't even know well I guess I do but
now what you want to do this
I gotta get away okay
okay so we're gonna do this again how
many times do you [ __ ] want angles
whoa where'd that come from
Wow what I didn't even see free whoa get
him get him get him grow I didn't even
see you it's really dark for me when I'm
playing so I apologize if I don't see
someone standing two inches in front of
me all right so that's one yeah I'm
gonna just grab some candy bars on the
way to my health now I got a bottle I
don't know if who's gonna be nearly as
effective as Rick what's that oh there's
a lot of them oh my god
deal okay they don't see me he'll need
to heal me to heal so bad oh my god what
about you downstairs
but the zombies really don't have time
for zom zoms right about okay you get
distracted but I'm like right in the
open air okay prick
let me alone I got a brick brick you
[ __ ] I'm gonna break you please don't
let that be a clicker behind me if it's
a clicker I'm gonna be very good oh no
no okay
you're gonna give Rick bricks work
effectively on zombies as well how about
Oh Oh change your mind
what's it yeah you got scared you scared
of the brick but it's scared of the
brick need to be afraid of the brick
Rick is gonna Jagger
yeah kill that guy
good job zom zom oh that's click no no
no no no no no why is that why is that I
think why is that thing why is it a
thing
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no I said a thing
[Music]
give me give me give me whatever that is
give me whatever that is what that he'd
that I didn't get that one but I needed
it oh my god the hell is going on here I
don't have any I don't have any left
I don't have any arrows either so I
can't kill him quietly do they expect
from me
I'm gonna go under the assumption that I
didn't know I don't know their where
they're gonna drop me off if I happen to
die that's not fair
so they're roaming upstairs like go back
downstairs I should be fine let me just
as a distraction
wait come on give a long throw oh yeah
that sounded serious better go
investigate that for about 10 hours
brick favorite I know it probably
doesn't matter but I think the brick is
far superior to the bottle for obvious
reasons I mean anyone who doesn't agree
with me is obviously some sort of a
communist I would think though I
actually need to kill them or do I can I
just walk around a minute more it's
gonna be loud if I open this gate I
think I've opened gates with closers I'm
down before oh I can't even open it I
got a killer okay I see how this is Oh
arrow thank goodness gravy anymore now
okay let's see what I could see
yes thank you so much Megan I think I'll
be okay
for now okay so my objective is sneak up
around one either arrow um brick America
dictum dick Wickham
plenty of animals oh there's a
as a normal zombie I think I can sneak
up on that one in there just knifing
thought oh that's not good
damn it why do they always have to be so
close together
oh it keeps moving don't trust myself
enough
where to go did you go downstairs
it did it what does this one is all mine
that's hardly fair hardly fair not fair
in fact not fair I'm gonna go ahead and
say not fair what did I get did I get I
didn't get anything what did I pick up
there's a brick it does not help me
does he not help me do you stay away
stay away stay away maybe I should just
try to shoot him I got enough bullets so
okay just try to stun one of them so
that
okay miss that's good miss like that
miss goodness that felt good I like that
no yeah yeah seriously that is a lot of
people that this little girl just killed
both zom zoms and normal maybe if he is
maybe you could have gettin off is
humping oh that does not seem flats
doors over there
someone could have just gone
[Music]
[Applause]
oh okay find something find something
find something how about this good
enough works for me
nope I got it I got it
don't worry now get rid of it
he's unprofitable these come from why
suddenly okay okay whatever you say I'm
following you to the ends of the earth I
knew that I knew that
whoo
can't believe they thought it was a good
idea turn on all the lights and good
good good oh so far that seems good
nothing
[Music]
[Music]
hmm I think it's clear le Millie your
arm
no-no-no
Oh
[Music]
don't worry I've done this before I'm
kind of an expert
really there's some more stuff over
there you can break where I see it we
got two options option 1 you take the
easy way out it's quick and painless I'm
not a fan of option 1 - we fight
hi for what we're gonna turn into one of
those things there are million ways we
should have died before today and a
million ways we can die before tomorrow
but we fight for every second we get to
spend with each other whether it's two
minutes
or two days we don't give that up
I don't want to give that up my boo
let's just wait it out you know we can
we all poetic and just lose our minds
together that's option three
sorry
come on let's get out
oh I knew it we all knew what was gonna
happen it's still you don't want it to
okay I finally see why they were doing
the parallel back and forth to that
point the story did you know Ellie and
Joel and then Ellie and Riley I see I
see how it went together and that was it
actually worked out so I don't ah
so so this whole story is just nothing
but tragedies
it's what zombie apocalypse would be
it'd be nothing but tragedy you can't
help it it'd be sad it'd be lost it'd be
just an endless life of misery and death
that's exactly what it would be but
anyway so that is the end of uh uh uh
the last of us are fine I'm not skip
this just in case you know with the
credit sequences mood music and whatnot
I don't know just uh do anything to do
with that but anyway that is that and
that's really sad it's really sad but we
all knew what it was gonna happen and
it's even worse because the thought that
Ellie cared about her so much and yet
had to go through all that and just like
even though they got to spend time with
each other she had to go through the
horrible realization that she's going
away and Ellie's not that that that
would be just awful at least you have
that hope in your mind that it could
cause skiers in there even though Joel
did his thing but that's another story
at this story but it's another this
story anyway that was really good I
really had fun with that um even my
unorthodox way of going through the
combat you know still good it works it's
legitimate I did it no no
well there you have it that was left
behind I really had fun with this this
really is great game awesome story I
love it to death
anyway thank you all so much for
watching clicking interface' for more
videos that i've done and as always I
will see you in the next
[Music]
get him get it